Stannis Baratheon: My brother, Robert Baratheon,
had raised the banners of Storm's End, our
ancestral castle, against the Mad King Aerys.
Jon Arryn of the Vale and Eddard Stark of
the North stood with him, and Hoster
Tully of the Riverlands would join.
But their lands were far from ours and
separated by the combined strength of the West,
the Reach, and King's Landing itself. Even
Robert's own lords were against him.
It was the hardest choice I've ever made: my
brother or my king, blood or honor. Aerys ruled
by right of all the laws in Westeros. Everyone
knew the price of defiance. But there are deeper,
older laws: the younger brother bows
before the elder. I followed Robert.
Early in the war, Mace Tyrell's indecisive
victory at Ashford cut Robert off from
Storm's End. Instead of pursuing Robert,
and risking his record, Mace Tyrell turned
east and laid siege to our home.
His vast army and navy encircled us
and preventing any resupply by land or sea.
If a wagon tried to reach us, it was burned.
If a ship tried to land, it was sunk.
We were locked inside Storm's End to starve.
But Robert had commanded me to hold the castle
no matter the cost. He could ill afford to lose
his ancient seat, which had never fallen.
While Robert smashed Rhaegar on the Trident,
my men ate the dogs because the horses had
already been devoured. While the Lannisters
sacked King's Landing, we ate the rats.
If the smuggler Davos had not slipped
through the Tyrell blockade with his
onions, we'd have eaten our own dead.
But I held the castle until Lord Eddard remembered
us, and marched to lift the siege. The Tyrells
didn't even put up a fight, and Robert threw a
feast to celebrate Lord Eddard's "victory."
I was sent to the royal island stronghold of
Dragonstone to deal with Viserys and Daenerys,
the last surviving Targaryen children.
Before I arrived, however, they had escaped
across the Narrow Sea. Robert was furious.
He stripped me of Storm's End and gave it to
that prancing fool Renly, my younger brother.
Davos Seaworth: Wars are not as good for smugglers
as you'd think. Every harbor fills with guards and
inspectors, and the seas fill with blockades and
pirates paid by each side to prey on the other.
Though I had no love for the Mad King, I'd grown
up around the power of King's Landing. I figured
this Robert Baratheon would end as the other rebel
lords: burned to ash. But he didn't.
The North, the Riverlands, and the Vale
joined him. And in the taverns, people
drank to Robert's health openly. "Brave
fools," I thought. But I had a family who'd
be left in the cold if I lost my head.
When Mace Tyrell marched on Robert's home at
Storm's End, I spied the end of the rebellion.
The castle was garrisoned by Robert's
younger brother Stannis and a small guard,
and would not hold out for long. When it fell,
Robert would be homeless, and his support would
bleed away. This, I knew from experience.
Months later, Stannis was still holding the
castle. Nobody cared. But on voyages, I had seen
what famine does; and I thought of all those
men in Storm's End, who would die unmourned and
forgotten. No better than Flea Bottom orphans.
I told his wife, and myself, that I'd get a high
price for the onions and salt beef. In truth,
I knew I'd be captured by the Tyrell galleys
or drowned. But I was too stubborn.
Later that night, in the dark, in a tiny boat
with a black sail, I cursed myself and the
moonlight as I waited for the tide to turn.
When it did, the wind beat the sail so hard
I ripped it down, fearing the Tyrell ships
would hear. Luckily, they had grown lax.
With muffled oars, alone, I steered my cargo
through the treacherous currents and snarls of
rock that gave Shipbreaker Bay its name.
The waves finally carried me, soaked and
near-blind from seawater, through the
mouth of the cavern beneath the castle.
Then Stannis Baratheon arrived.
The siege had left him gaunt,
but not weak, never weak. He greeted me
and accepted my onions with cool courtesy,
betraying no emotion even as all wept.
He doled out the food to his wife and each
of his men before he ate himself, a portion no
larger than any other. When he finally thanked me,
I could see his mind had already returned
to the castle's defense. His duty.
After Aerys fell and Lord Stark lifted
the siege, Stannis summoned me. For my
salvation of Storm's End, I was to be granted
a knighthood, a keep of my own, and my son
taken into Stannis's personal service.
"Davos of Flea Bottom" had become "Ser
Davos of House Seaworth," and my son
would serve the king's own brother.
But for my previous crimes as a smuggler, I
was to have the fingertips of one hand taken
off above the highest joint. Stannis held that
I had flouted the laws of the land for years,
and a good act does not wash out the bad.
In one fell swoop, or five, Stannis gave my son
a future and my family a name that I could've
never imagined, nor earned, on my own.
I still keep the finger bones in a bag
around my neck to remind me of what I was,
and what I owe to Stannis.
For during my many years as a smuggler,
I visited many ports, taverns, and back
alleys, and saw many things in this world,
but never justice. Until Stannis.
Robert Baratheon: Rebellion! The
crimes of House Targaryen were too heinous to go
unanswered. The noble Houses of Baratheon, Stark,
and Arryn, united to oppose and overthrow
the line of the cursed dragon kings.
While Ned Stark and Arryn secured an
alliance with the Tullys of Riverrun,
I called the banners of Storm's End and
rode out in force against the Mad King and
his minions. Gods, those were some battles!
Our first victory occurred at Summerhall where I
faced off against an army of dragon loyalists and
won three battles in a single day, three in one
day! Seven hells, that was a glorious day!
We tried to take Ashford Castle in the Reach,
but the Tyrells beat us back. We had to regroup.
My army was pursued north by Aerys's army and took
refuge in the Stoney Sept in the Riverlands.
When the Targaryen army entered the town,
the sept bells tolled, a signal to the
townspeople of the battle that was to
come. As the Targaryens searched from house to
house for me, the combined forces of Ned Stark
and the Tullys swept into the city.
Gods, what a day that was! It's now
known as the Battle of the Bells. We
overwhelmed the Mad King's forces and
sent them scampering back to King's Landing.
Aerys's son, Rhaegar, who started the whole damn
thing, finally emerged from hiding in the South
and assembled his own army to face us. As for the
Mad King, he must have been pissing himself.
The battle that would decide the fate of the
Seven Kingdoms occurred at the crossing
of the Green Fork of the Trident river.
Rhaegar commanded the royal host, which
was some forty thousand strong.
My forces were outnumbered by nearly five thousand
men, but that didn't matter. They were fresh,
but we were battle-hardened
and had justice on our side.
As the battle raged around us, I faced off
with Rhaegar. The stag and the dragon right
there in the ford of the river. I
fought with the fury of ten men,
raining blow after blow upon that vile prince
before burying my war hammer in his chest.
I hit him so hard, the rubies on his
armor broke free, flinging them into
the stream. They call it the Ruby Ford now.
With that scum Rhaegar dead and the royal army
shattered, our next move was to make for King's
Landing. But I'd sustained a few wounds in the
battle and was unable to ride. I sent Ned
Stark to the capital to face the Mad King
and make him pay for his crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: The Targaryens,
blood of the dragon and the last of Old
Valyria, were loved by their subjects and
admired far and wide as the greatest dynasty
in the history of the western world.
But the peace and prosperity of nearly
three centuries of Targaryen rule
were shattered by the Usurper, Robert
Baratheon, and his band of traitors.
House Baratheon owed its very existence to
the Targaryens. Was it not Aegon the Dragon,
himself, who elevated the bastard Orys
Baratheon in the War of Conquest?
And what of the Starks? The
Lannisters? The Arryns of the Vale?
All had been spared and allowed to keep their
lands when Aegon could easily have wiped them
out. Centuries later, the Usurper and his lackeys
repaid Aegon's benevolence with treachery.
There are some who dare to claim Robert and
his allies had reason to rebel. They say the
crown prince stole the Usurper's lady love.
They say my father, King Aerys, murdered Rickard
Stark and his son without just cause. Whether
these charges are true or not, it doesn't
matter! The dragon answers to no one.
Aerys's good name has been besmirched in
the years since the rebellion. He has been
called a dangerous madman, a monster, a tyrant
that brought his tragic end upon himself.
Lies! My father was a victim of weaklings
in his council! Lackwits who
failed him in his hour of need,
and let the rebellion spin out of control!
But it was not enough. The royal army was crushed
at the Battle of the Trident. It was there the
valiant Rhaegar met Robert in single combat,
but the gods betrayed him, and he
perished by the Usurper's hand.
As the Field of Fire had marked the end of the
Andals centuries before, the Battle of the Trident
seemed to herald the end of the dragon kings.
When word reached the capital of my brother
Rhaegar's death, my father Aerys moved to protect
me, as I was the surviving heir to the throne.
He sent me to the island fortress of Dragonstone,
along with my mother, Queen Rhaella, who was great
with child. But as my father, my king, Aerys
Targaryen, prepared to defend his throne to the
bitter end, little did he know of the horrors
and betrayals that awaited him and our family.